>>> LISTEN, IT'S FRIDAY AND IN
POLITICS SOMETIMES YOU JUST HAVE
TO LAUGH.
MY NEXT GUESTS ARE ALL ABOUT
THAT.
THEY'RE COMEDIANS WHO ARE WAGING
THEIR OWN VERSION OF TRUMP
VERSUS BERNIE DEBATE TOUR 2016.
>> I THINK IT'S A TREMENDOUS AND
INCREDIBLY EXPIALIDOCIOUS THING
YOU DO.
>> WAIT A MINUTE, WAIT A MINUTE.
>> TRUMP VERSUS BERNIE CURRENTLY
PLAYING COMEDY CLUBS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
HERE WITH ME NOW I HAVE TONY
ATAMONIC AS DONALD TRUMP, JAMES
AS BERNIE SANDERS.
LET ME BE TOTALLY TRANSPARENT
WITH YOU AT HOME, THEY HAVE BEEN
IN CHARACTER THE ENTIRE TIME.
I DON'T KNOW WHO YOU REALLY ARE.
>> SENATOR SANDERS.
>> SO NICE TO MEET YOU.
MR. TRUMP.
>> I'M BILLIONAIRE DONALD TRUMP
AND THERE'S AN IMPOSTER RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT, I CAN TELL YOU
THAT.
>> SO, SENATOR SANDERS.
>> SURE.
>> IF I MAY BEGIN WITH YOU.
>> NO PROBLEM.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK YOU'RE THE
RIGHT PERSON FOR THE JOB TO
UNIFY THIS COUNTRY.
>> I THINK, AND THIS IS JUST
WHAT I THINK, I THINK IT'S FAR
TOO LONG THAT THE TOP 1% OF THE
TOP 10% OF THE TOP 1% OF THE TOP
10% CONTROLS MORE PERCENTAGES
THAN ALL THE OTHER PERCENTAGES.
>> MR. TRUMP IS SHAKING HIS
HEAD.
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS.
WE'RE LOSING ALL THE TIME.
I WILL NOT TURN THIS FLAG RIGHT
SIDE UP AND THAT'S WHEN THE
UNITED STATES IS WINNING AND
THAT'S WHEN I'M PRESIDENT.
WHEN WE STARTED, WE HAD 17
CANDIDATES AND I HAVE SURVIVED
EVERY ROSE CEREMONY.
I'VE SURVIVED EVERY ROSE
CEREMONY AND I AM SURE WHEN IT
COMES TO GETTING KNOCKED OFF THE
ISLAND, I WILL SURVIVE.
>> MR. TRUMP A BIG FAN OF THE
BACHELOR AND SURVIVOR.
>> I THINK IT'S ALSO NOT FAIR
THAT 200% OF EVERYTHING GOES TO
1% OF MR. TRUMP SITTING NEXT TO
ME.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FIGHTING
AGAINST.
>> OKAY.
LET ME BE SERIOUS FOR A SECOND.
>> VERY SERIOUS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
CAN WE CHANNEL JIM AND TONY?
SO YOU GUYS ARE COMEDIANS.
YOU'RE WRITTEN FOR 30 ROCK,
BROAD CITY, THESE ARE SHOWS,
THIS IS WHAT YOU DO FOR A
LIVING.
HOW DID YOU COMING TOGETHER AND
DISCOVER THIS AND FIND TWO WIGS
TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN?
>> OKAY.
I WILL BE JAMES.
WHAT I DID IS I HAD A BIG PILE
OF CLOTHES AND COSTUMES AND I
JUST KIND OF DOVE INTO IT LIKE
AN OLYMPIC DIVER.
>> AND THIS IS WHAT YOU WOUND UP
WITH.
>> YEAH.
>> BRAVO.
FIRST OF ALL, I WAS A SILENT
WRITER AT 30 ROCK.
I STARTED DOING TRUMP AS A LARK.
I DID A SHOW AT THE UPRIGHT
CITIZENS BRIGADE THEATER ON
SUNDAY NIGHTS.
MY FRIEND, SHANNON O'NEILL,
WHO'S THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR,
SAID YOU DO AN INCREDIBLE TRUMP.
I CAN'T START DOING IT.
>> STOP MOVING THE HANDS.
>> AND I SEE IT AS AN ACT OF
COMEDIC ACTIVISM.
I WANT TO TAKE EVERYTHING TRUMP
SAID AND BRING IT TO HIS FINAL
POINTS.
WHEN HE'S TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS, I WANT TO TAKE IT
FURTHER.
>> ARE YOU FOLLOWING ALL OF THE
TWISTS AND THE TURNS TO MAKE
SURE WHAT YOU'VE SAYING IS
TOTALLY ON POINT?
YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW TWITTER?
>> YEAH, WE WATCH YOU.
>> I'VE BEEN AHEAD OF TRUMP TWO
MONTHS.
I HAVE A SPEECH FROM MY SHOW ON
OCTOBER 24th TALKING ABOUT
COMING IN SECOND IN IOWA.
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SOUTH
CAROLINA, SENATOR.
>> I THINK SOUTH CAROLINA IS
DOWN THERE, IT'S RIGHT
UNDERNEATH NORTH CAROLINA AND I
THINK IT'S IN THE TOP 50% OF
CAROLINAS IN THE COUNTRY.
>> IT'S NOT LOOKING GOOD FOR
YOU.
>> IF WE CAN CLOSE IT WITHIN 10%
WE'RE GOING TO CALL IT A
VICTORY.
>> I WOULD PROMISE SOUTH
CAROLINA THIS, FIRST OFF, WE'RE
GOING TO WIN, IT'S GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLE.
BUT HERE'S THE THING, I WANT TO
PURCHASE THE GREAT PACIFIC
GARBAGE PATCH AND MAKE IT THE
51st STATE OF THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK IT'S A PERFECT PLACE FOR
IMMIGRANTS AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
>> BACK TO JIM AND TONY.
HOW DO CROWDS REACT TO YOU?
ARE THEY BOOING, ARE THEY
CHEERING?
DOES IT DEPEND IF YOU'RE IN THE
CITY OR IN VERMONT?
>> GENERALLY THEY BOO HIM AND
CHEER BERNIE.
>> SORRY, TRUMP.
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
BY THE END THEY CHEER ME.
>> YOU WIN THEM OVER.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE PROUD.
>> I MAKE REAL POINTS.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP WOULD NOT
BE PROUD OF MY IMPRESSION.
DONALD, IF YOU'RE WATCHING, I
WANT TO MEET YOU, PLEASE.
LET'S TALK IN A MIRROR.
>> BERNIE, LOOK, LET'S GET IN
SOME HARD NUMBERS.
I WANT TO READ THE TRANSPACIFIC
PARTNERSHIP BACK AND FORTH TO
EACH OTHER.
IT WILL BE ROMANTIC.
>> FINAL THOUGHTS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> TRUMP VERSUS BERNIE.COM.
>> I WAS ENDORSED BY A WHITE
SUPREMACIST GROUP.
I THINK THAT'S ALL YOU NEED TO
KNOW.
>> JIM, TONY, DONALD, BERNIE --
>> YOU'RE A WONDERFUL FEMALE.
>> I GIVE THE BALANCE OF MY TIME
TO YOU.
>> IF PEOPLE AT HOME COULD SEE
THIS -- I HAVE NEVER SEEN SUCH A
MASSIVE CROWD AS I'M SEEING
RIGHT NOW.
>> OF COURSE THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO COULDN'T GET INTO THIS -- IT
WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> AND IT'S